ich hasse eigentlich so ein Staat für
solche Videos wenn man so
Kamera anmacht und dann setzt man sich
hin und
redet und es real und alles mögliche
aber
es muss sein
ihr seht ja bereits im Titel das dieses
Video hier wirklich das mit Abstand
wichtigste Videos dass ich hier
hochgeladen habe auf Youtube generell
ich mache den ganzen Kram selbst schon
seit 11 Jahren und habe all in all fast
4000 Videos hochgeladen und glaubt mir
das ist kein clickbait was hier im Titel
steht
es wird mir eh nichts bringen hier views
drauf zu generieren weil ich die Werbung
deaktiviert habe also ich verdiene mit
keinen Cent mir geht es einfach nur
darum euch über etwas sehr Wichtiges zu
informieren darüber zu reden und ähnlich
wie damals bei meinem Panikattacken
Video von ein paar Jahren vielleicht
auch ein bisschen Erfahrungen
auszutauschen und
auch dieses Video
ansatzweise als kleine Therapie
zu nutzen aber worum geht es überhaupt
ihr seht mich
[Musik]
in Youtube Videos
tiktoks Instagram Stories Beiträgen
Podcast oder vielleicht sogar auf
irgendwelchen Events wenn ich mal auf
einer Bühne bin oder vor Leuten
irgendwie was mache immer als
lustig dummen Trottel
bei dem
es glaube ich für Außenstehende aus der
Sicht betrachtet immer so auswärts wer
bei mir alles in Ordnung als wäre ich
vielleicht
ja wirklich ein perfekter Mensch in
vielen Augen glaube ich von euch
aber ich kann euch nur sagen ich bin
kein guter Mensch
ehrlich gesagt bin ich ein ziemlich
schlechter Mensch versteht bitte dass
ich dieses Video nicht mache um Mitleid
zu bekommen
weil realtalk das habe ich einfach nicht
verdient ich mache dieses Video hier
auch nicht um
mich auszukotzen über meinen Beruf oder
das was ich mache ich bin unendlich
dankbar das habe ich ja schon übel
häufig gesagt dass ich das was mir seit
diesen zehn elf Jahren wo ich das mache
dass ich das beruflich machen durfte
nach einer Zeit dass ich damit nach
einer Zeit plötzlich Geld verdient habe
dass ich mir davon mein Leben
finanzieren konnte mir eine Existenz
aufbauen konnte darum geht es mir gar
nicht
es geht mir um was viel tieferes und
zwar geht es mir um mich als Menschen
der besonders in den letzten Jahren
leider
sehr viele Fehler gemacht hat
und das alles irgendwie weiß ich nicht
versucht gerade so ein bisschen
aufzuarbeiten wenn ihr dieses Video hier
seht
bin ich bereits in Therapie
ich
hatte dann bereits die ersten Stunden
oder keine Ahnung Stunde keine Ahnung
und
versuche alles so ein bisschen zu
verstehen warum ich in vielen
Situationen
nicht der luca war der ich vielleicht
noch vor einigen Jahren war
sondern
[Musik]
keine Ahnung ich glaube für euch als
Zuschauer also ich glaube wenn Freunde
von mir wirklich enge Leute meine
Familie solche Menschen dieses Video
sehen die wissen glaube ich worum es
hier geht aber
will auch jetzt nicht auf jedes kleinste
Teil eingehen das war eigentlich ein
ganz kurzes Video hier nur werden
ich glaube aber dass ihr wirklich 99,9%
der Leute die das hier gerade gucken gar
nicht wissen was gerade abgeht weil ich
ja ihr guckt meine Instagram Stories ihr
seht ich mache dumme jokes ihr seht
tiktoks von mir ich Hampel da rum wir
waren jetzt die Tage hier auf einer
Kreuzfahrt da habe ich lustig dummen
konnte dann haben wir da gemacht die
Tage kommt auch noch ein Vlog von der
ganzen Reise so wenn ich abgelenkt bin
wenn ich irgendwie arbeite vor allem
oder wenn ich mit meiner Familie bin und
damit Leuten die gut zu mir sind dann
verdränge ich das häufig dass ich ein
schlechter Mensch bin aber es geht mir
um euch noch so ein paar Stichpunkte zu
nennen warum es mir gerade geht
geht's mir darum dass ich einfach
wirklich ein arroganter Wixer bin ich
habe narzisstische Züge die ich besiegen
muss ich habe
ich habe mich oft sehr sehr stur
Verhalten nicht nur Freunden gegenüber
sondern generell Mitmenschen hatte oft
nur einen Blick dass ich durchziehen
will dass ich meinen Krams machen will
dass ich erfolgreich sein möchte habe
häufig auf Gefühle geschissen habe
gedacht ich wäre immer
der wichtigste der die beste Meinung hat
die auch umgesetzt werden sollte
ich habe mir sehr sehr häufig gedacht
hey wenn ich ein Problem habe
wenn ich
wenn irgendwas bei mir ist was mich
belastet dann mache ich das mit mir
selbst aus weil ich nicht verletzlich
rüberkommen wollte
weil ich nicht meine Freunde Familie
oder keine Ahnung bin damit belasten
wollte wenn es mir schlecht ging
ich habe mir immer gesagt hey ich merke
das ist blöd das hat sich irgendwie so
und so verändert das gefällt mir so
nicht dass es irgendwie scheiße oder
auch wenn es um Trauer ging die mir
geht's jetzt nicht irgendwie nur um
Todesfälle oder um irgendwelche
Situationen die es gab oder keine Ahnung
wenn man sich benachteiligt gefühlt hat
oder egal was ich habe immer alles mit
mir selber ausgemacht ich war bei einem
Therapeuten in Hamburg für ein paar
Wochen um einfach auch noch mal bei
meiner Panikattacken damals zu sprechen
die ich ja hatte aufgrund des Stress
diese leichten Burnout Erscheinungen die
ich damals hatte aber ich konnte mich
auch ihm gegenüber nie wirklich öffnen
und habe dann irgendwann einfach gesagt
ey das bringt hier nichts
und ich glaube ich muss einfach und das
habe ich jetzt in den letzten Tagen
gemerkt und der Funke ist übergesprungen
dass ich jetzt einfach so intensiv wie
es nur geht an mir selber arbeiten
möchte
und das auch nicht für irgendwelche
anderen Menschen mache sondern in erster
Linie und das soll nicht egoistisch
stehen aber erster Linie wirklich für
mich
weil ich selber merke dass ich
glaube ich mal mit Menschen nicht so gut
tue wie ich das
häufig
fälschlicherweise gedacht habe
und ja ich will gar nicht mehr lange
quatschen mir geht's einfach nur darum
dass ihr darüber informiert seid dass
wenn jetzt beispielsweise in den
nächsten Wochen tendenziell vielleicht
eher weniger Videos kommen auf meinem
zweitkanal sind wir relativ weit im
voraus da
sollte denke ich weiter daily Content
kommen oder fast daily Content aber auf
dem Hauptkanal wenn ich einmal sehr nah
dran an der Zeit da wird tendenziell
wirklich sehr viel weniger kommen die
nächsten Wochen aber nur dass ihr
bescheid wisst falls ich mich mal ein
paar Tage nicht melde
falls mal doch kein Video kommt oder
falls
Instagram Beiträge kommen bei mir eh nur
drei vier Stück im Jahr von daher sollte
mich da glaube ich niemand vermissen
aber nur so vom Ding her dass
ja einfach wisst was bei mir los ist
weil no joke ihr seid halt mir über die
Jahre echt ans Herz gewachsen auch wenn
ich nur ganz kleinen Bruchteil von euch
überhaupt mal in echt getroffen habe
hilft es mir extrem doll einfach wenn
ich dann meine die Ems durchlesen und
ich sehe mir wird jede Sekunde irgendwie
ein positiver positive Nachricht
geschrieben oder so das auch wenn das
von Unbekannten es hilft einem das
wirklich enormen weil ich gerade sehr an
mir am Zweifeln bin einfach
und ja einfach
so ein bisschen
an mir arbeiten muss jetzt in nächster
Zeit erstmal und ich tue das jetzt schon
seit
ein paar Tagen intensiv mit mir selber
aber jetzt halt auch mit professioneller
Hilfe
und
ja ich werde euch da auf dem Laufenden
halten so gut ich kann nicht
will jetzt natürlich nicht weil jedes
einzelne Detail sprechen aber
enge Leute in meinem Umfeld wissen auf
jeden Fall Bescheid und was da geht und
ja wollt euch nur darüber informieren
also nur noch mal ich möchte hier kein
Mitleid von euch haben ich
möchte mich überhaupt nicht beschweren
oder irgendwie in die Schuld geben das
habe ich in den letzten Jahren genug
gemacht ich habe nie den Fehler bei mir
selbst gesucht und ich
bin jetzt einfach glaube ich
endlich bereit
mal damit zu arbeiten
um
das Beste aus mir rauszuholen und der
beste Mensch zu werden der ich sein kann
danke dass ihr euch gibt
danke dass ihr
bisschen dran geblieben seid und
ja wir sehen uns
dann die Tage wieder